So a capital allocator, explain
what that job is in the world,
and do you have any, I was thinking about
this today when I was in the shower,
I was like, where did this concept of
capital allocators even originate from, I,
we know about carry and
that when, you know,
ships used to go to the what
was then called the orient or to
India to get spice or whatever
somebody would say, hey, listen,
if you get the package back here,
I'll give you 20% of whatever makes
it back to shore. You get carry,
you get a portion of what comes
back and that aligned interest.
So we know that piece,
where did the concept of a
capital allocator even come from?
I think it's relatively new. If I go back,
I started my career in 1992. And just
to give you a perspective at the time,
there were no more than a half a
dozen of these offices in the country.
And I think I was the only junior
analysts looking at funds in
the entire country, like Yale
used to hire one undergrad a year.
And so Harvard had an office,
but they were mostly direct
investing and Stanford had an office,
but there were four or five, you
know, senior people. There are very,
very few of them.
The reason I think it's come to pass
has kind of goes hand in hand with the
notion of modern portfolio
theory in that if you
have a large pool of capital and you're
trying to preserve and grow it for a
long period of time and their
spending needs along the way,
people have adopted the notion
that you want to be diversified.
And so the question is, if you
were 4 or 5 people, you know,
maybe it was 10 or 12 back
then and a little more today,
but you're 4 or 5 people sitting
in new Haven, Connecticut,
and you want to diversify around the
world. You have two options, right?
One is you could say, okay,
let's go figure out how to compete
with Jason and all the other seed stage
venture capitalist, and
we'll compete with Sequoia.
And then let's go to Asia and what
we'll pick Chinese stocks. And Oh,
by the way,
we probably want to be in large cap and
small cap stocks in the US and equity
and credit, Oh, we need expertise in
the bond markets. At some point in time,
your head starts spinning and say,
well, we can do one of two things.
We can either try to compete with
an increasingly specialized world,
or we can just go try to identify them.
Let's develop our skillset to try to
identify the best and partner with them.
And so that,
that became a model that went hand in
hand with this kind of strategy and really
got popularized
when David Swenson wrote his kind
of seminal book called portfolio,
Pioneering Portfolio Management in 2000,
and then you started to see proliferation
of more of these offices and more LPs
and these strategies. And so the,
the clear path to becoming a capital
allocator at one of these endowments
was to have been an alumni of that
place for some reason. Is that correct?
I mean, I suppose right there,
one of the things that's interesting
about my show is when I interview a bunch
of these CIOs, there is no clear path.
Because the fact is the industry
didn't exist 20 years ago.
So how could you have been trained in
it? Ah, yes. That makes total sense.
It's like asking for somebody to be
like a, an AR developer it's like,
or, you know, an AI developer. Well, yeah,
it's been accessible now for 30
years, but yes, people were like,
I need a iPhone app developer with five
years experience when the app store
had just came out,
people wouldn't put up ads for that
because it doesn't make any sense.